Monsieur Jacques Martin laissez-moi
parler encore une fois alors
et voilà ce que je tiens à dire et je
voudrais le lire je voudrais le dire
devant les téléspectateurs façon à
m'expliquer clairement parce que tout
est confusion encore l'autre jour dans
les grosses têtes vous participez à
cette émission qui était complètement je
trouve grotesque ridicule qu'il faisait
Paris
que les gens qui étaient dans le coin et
qui était
obligé de rire parce qu'ils étaient là
et que les gens qui sont là il faut
qu'il rigole monsieur
et vous n'avez pas fini d'entendre
parler de vous on va se marrer de votre
position pendant des mois
je vous connais je suis suffisamment je
vous avais travaillé avec les GMF vous
avez fait des choses qui étaient pas mal
dans certaines de vos émissions je les
regarde et je ne m'en trouve pas plus
mal il y a donc
un travail à la télé moins bonne la
partie
sur
votre position à la présence de Pierre
Desproges et nous l'avions enregistré il
y a quelques temps et je voudrais je
voudrais Jacques Martin laissez-moi
parler s'il vous plaît je voudrais que
tout de suite puisque on ne peut pas
être sur le plateau nous allons écouter
la réponse qu'il avait enregistré après
l'interview donnée par Monseigneur
Lustin G
Pierre Desproges vous avez décidé à
votre tour d'écrire à une haute autorité
je suis indigné moi-même
c'est une lettre ouverte à Monseigneur
Lustiger
chers Seigneur
qu'il me soit permis de m'indigner ici
véhément contre les insupportables
attaques portées régulièrement à la
télévision à mon athéisme militant par
vos camarades de goupillons il est
intolérable deux siècles après la
séparation de l'Église et de l'État dans
un pays qui pousse la laïcité officielle
au rang d'institutions nationales que
des anti athées hystériques accaparent
l'antenne de la télévision le dimanche
matin avec des émissions intitulées je
cite la messe du dimanche dans laquelle
les minorités athées non brillantes non
bigotante et maltifiante sont méprisées
et bafoués et je pèse mes mots au profit
de grotesque manifestations
incantatoires d'une secte en robe dont
le monothéisme avoué est une véritable
insulte à Darwin aux religions
gréco-romaines et à ma soeur qui fait
bouddhiste dans un bordel de Kuala
Lumpur voilà je précise que j'envoie par
ce même courrier une copie de cette
lettre à Dieu et que ça va chieront
les verront d'après cette exposé de
Monsieur Desproges pourquoi je n'ai pas
envie de le rencontrer
un petit mot Jacques Martinique
et comment vous situez pas une chose
être chrétien c'est accepter la
différence
je crois que
la religion a beaucoup de choses à se
reprocher et s'il y a eu un pape qui a
fait quelque chose de grandiose au nom
de l'amour au nom de la dignité humaine
c'est Jean XXII qui a aboli et supprimé
des textes sur lesquels vous apprenez la
religion la notion par exemple pour les
Juifs de peuple ici
je voudrais dire aussi une chose
c'est que
des proches doit être très certainement
quelqu'un qui est un ancien élève de
l'église
son texte bon et harnieux mais je le
supporte je l'accepte le Christ a
supporté bien d'autres choses on lui a
craché dessus on lui enfoncer une
couronne d'épines et on lui a mis un
bourgeon dans la main en disant voilà
ton sceptre
il a accepté Monsieur le Prince Minguet
bon et bien je vous félicite d'être plus
chrétien que le Christ encore oui
ce que je voudrais vous dire c'est ceci
les gens qui sont réunis et les gens qui
ont accepté de signer un manifeste dans
tous les mots sont pesés et dont vous
vous oh j'ai vu l'eau
n'importe quoi à ce sujet là on le
trafic tout à fait j'ai des paroles j'ai
repris le texte
concentration
est-ce que vous pensez qu'un
intellectuel peut
la libre expression des déverses
croyances fondent notre unité les
agressions envers ce qui lui est sacré
atteigne chez le croyant les réseaux
essentielles de vivre d'espérer d'aimer
elle blesse les consciences elles vont à
l'encontre des droits de l'homme de tous
les hommes quel que soit leur
spiritualité et pour réagir contre
l'intolérance manifester par ses
agressions et pour resserrer l'union de
nos concitoyens par le respect
réciproque de leur motivation les plus
profondes se crée ce comité son rôle
n'est pas
laissé parler
son rôle n'est pas de dénoncer un
anticléricalisme bien de chez nous donc
nous sommes pas pour dénoncer
l'Antiquité
ni même l'immoralité
il évitera trois écueils la récupération
politique le cléricalisme le moralisme
il est constitué par des personnes
connues pour leur indépendance aucune
d'elles n'étant désignée par une église
une confession ou une communauté les
principaux courants spirituels
catholiques protestants orthodoxe
musulman agnostique franc-maçon athée
et je voudrais pour terminer non non
mais laissez-moi je ne veux pas
30 secondes il y a deux formes
d'expression il y a des pétitions les
textes qu'on envoie la pression
[Musique]